[Music]  it's his son  his only son  i need to know who's responsible i'll  kill my son  we've deployed large amounts of time  money and effort  in the search for justice not good  enough it's got to be an inside job  you're going to have to go undercover  there's an army truck driver  we have a new addition may i introduce h  cash trucks can be dangerous  [Music]  they're serious leave this to me  [Music]  you work for suck my [ __ ] dick  what did you say i said  we need a different approach boss it's  not any of the usual suspects  what do you want me to do i can do it  two weeks you know what i wish you could  do in 20 years  you're going to give me a name i need to  face  i need to understand resourcefulness  seriously  on a dudebury grudge  if he's not a cop what is he  he's a dark [ __ ] spirit  [Music]  you